well I want to speak regarding the issue
of my particular Council which is
chronic disease and well-being and the
Rays of chronic diseases is becoming so
heavy that it's putting a burden on
government expenditures in hell on
out-of-pocket expenditures for family on
the burden of disabilities for the
recovery of the economy and this is
creating even more pockets of poverty
for those who are trying to break the
head above the way so we are calling
attention that there is very easy ways
to address and prevent the current
epidemic of chronic diseases and we are
also inviting everybody to take
advantage of the UN summit that is going
to happen in September 2011 which will
bring all HESA governments into thinking
about how to prevent chronic diseases to
becoming one of the crashes of the
you